I'm Trevor nwol a solution engineer at
posit and back in 2016 I failed my
co-worker
Sam so imagine this Sam wait from his
commute has 10 minutes to spare before
an important executive meeting he comes
racing in the office fires up a shiny
app to grab the latest report and this
happen
happens oh no undefined column Sam
quickly has to grab the report from
yesterday and explain it well the
meeting did not go well I failed my
coworker but let's look at why this
happened so Friday I push a tiny fix to
my app I give it a few quick tests
manually and uh it's the end of the day
and so I forget to deploy it but I
figure I'll do it early on Monday
Monday rolls around I deploy the app
thinking it's working and then the
Fateful Tuesday happens Sam has trouble
getting the report and it really hurts
his
performance but the good news is that
was back in
2016 let's look at an alternative
reality if this happened in 2023 with
better
tooling so now I make my tiny fix but
this time I push it up to my GitHub repo
and my cicd pipeline runs does a test
and flags the error the shiny app
doesn't look
right that's great I can go back and I
can make the fix on Monday I get in a
little early because I know the error
occurred I saw it in my email I make the
changes push it up to GitHub my cicd
pipeline runs test succeed and and great
it deploys the new version of my app to
my
server now Sam runs in 10 minutes to
spare goes to the app downloads the
report it comes out really fast he can
drink his coffee he gets his caffeine
hit he goes to his meeting he gets a
huge promotion he becomes my boss he's
the CEO of the company and he buys a
sports team someday a wildly successful
career what a great alternative reality
we should all live in this world so
let's look at how I got
here so first I set up a cicd pipeline I
use GitHub actions but there's other
tools I'll talk about at the end there's
two main pieces continuous integration
running the test I used a package shiny
Test 2 which allows you to record your
screen it's great and record how your
app behaves and then continuous
delivery
this deploys my app to connect only if
the CI steps are successful so only at
the end of the
pipeline it's a great time to be setting
up cicd pipelines and this is because in
GitHub actions there's a lot of
community pre-built steps I've left some
links here our web has a number of them
for useful for our users um and our
studio has some as well and the purpose
of this talk is not to go through code
but I did want to show just how easy it
is to set up your own
pipeline you can compose different steps
kind of like packages into your pipeline
so here I set up R I set up my RM
environment I run the test and I publish
to connect it's really this simple and
you can do it too if there's one
takeaway from this talk that I want you
to have is to run out and set up your
own pipeline what do you have to
lose and there's a couple benefits the
main ones are deploying from get repos
how nice is it that I can just commit to
my repo and then trust my pipeline will
do the rest it'll automate the tests
it'll only deploy the content after
testing and the result of all this is my
users will trust me it's a good feeling
to know that when you log onto an app
it's going to be successful and that
grows the user base within your company
and there's a lot of other tools I
talked about GitHub actions but if
you're using any of these other ones
contact your devops team or others on
your team that have access and get
started they all are fairly easy to use
and your team may already have some
actions in the pipeline that you don't
even know
about I'll leave you with a few
resources um you're always welcome to
contact me and reach out with any
questions I'm happy to help get out
there and make some awesome
Pipelines